I live right outside of Boston I live
about five miles away so it's a real
inner suburb it's not a phenomenon that
you could really find in New York we
have a small town that's that close to
the city you know and and I really find
that to be a nice way to live because
you have you know the best of both
worlds in a sense the thing I've been
really thinking about lately what was
what would happen with gas prices over
the summer when they spiked up to four
dollars a gallon they've since dropped
because we're in the midst of this
financial crisis but at that time I was
thinking very frequently about in the
Boston area if you wanted to buy a house
for under say $300,000 you'd have to
move out of the city maybe like 45
minutes and you had a long commute and I
know they're people outside a la who do
this as well outside of every major city
outside Atlanta you know you have to
drive 45 minutes to an hour or more both
ways you know to get to and from work
and I really felt like we're on the
verge of that whole suburban lifestyle
being economically untenable that
they're going to be these distant and I
think you know some planners have been
talking about this they're going to be
these suburbs that are in effect going
to be like inner-city ghettos you know
they're going to be abandoned and
they're going to become you know they're
going to be out a couple houses that are
inhabited on a street full of you know
boarded up big old homes you know it may
be a dystopian vision that is too
extreme but you can policy how that
could happen and you can see a you know
the values of homes near the city and
near public transportation shooting up
and the value of homes you know half
hour or more from the city you know
really plummeting and you know just a
big demographic shake-up in our culture
and and a lot of anger I think you know
you can see the beginnings of it in
terms of people you know realizing they
can't drive the rescue v's and you know
people realizing that they built homes
that were too big I mean I think it's
going to seem pretty shocking you know
50 or 100 years down the line for people
to think that in the 1990s and you know
early two thousand people were building
these gigantic houses and driving these
gigantic cars even though they knew that
you know it wasn't sustainable
economically that we just didn't have
the oil to you know to do